i would like to give
ron the opportunity to say a few words
about
why he and his business partner started
the scholarship fund
and allow us all to hear his wisdom
thank you tom i am fully vaccinated and
had coveted in july so i'm going to take
the mask off for a few seconds
it's really an honor to be able to speak
to you here today and to commend
the recipients of this scholarship
award my business partner don and i
used to own a business in town called
planet hyundai
and after the tragic assassination
of officers beck and soldo don and i
met to discuss doing something to show
the department
what the job they do every day means to
us as local business owners
i've been in the tavern business for
over 30 years
so anybody in the las vegas tavern
business knows cops
because they're always stopping by
checking on your staff 24
7. but in the car business don and i
were very lucky to be fortunate with
that investment
and to do well enough that after that
tragic day
i suggested to don that we start a
scholarship fund
in the memory of officers beck and soldo
and that was seven years ago it's hard
to believe
we did a 50 000 offer
um as a result of that i joined the
foundation board
to help decide who would receive the 5
000
scholarships 10 of which this year
there's 12.
and it was one of my happier days of all
the boards i've served on
and businesses i've owned to serve with
the group
such as the las vegas metropolitan
police department foundation board
members
and the work we do to show the officers
of the department
how much we appreciate what they do so
picture us one day thinking what can we
do for cops
cops are used to taking care of
themselves and everyone else
and we came up with the idea to do a
scholarship for their kids
and let them know through gifts to their
children
starting college how much the jobs they
do
mean to us and as i said that was seven
years ago we did fifty thousand dollars
at an
as an initial contribution and as long
as we stayed in the car business we did
that
for six consecutive years awarding a
total of three hundred thousand dollars
and now this year the foundation which
has grown when i joined it
chris and tom we had about a hundred
thousand dollars in the bank
and uh three board members with mike
mcclary
and tom and it's grown significantly
since then to a multi-million dollar
foundation
that this year is funding the twelve
scholarships
as a foundation i'm honored and proud to
be able to say we started it
and and hopefully can continue it
through the
generosity of the community towards the
foundation
so congratulations to the 12 recipients
who i look forward to meeting
individually as we make the awards
and commend you for reaching this height
of
performance that's being rewarded and
maybe
the first financial reward you got for
doing a good job
and as you begin your life in adulthood
you will see many rewards to come for
doing the best job
possible as you did against over 60
competitors for these scholarships so i
commend you
and thank you for making this possible
for me to do
thank you tom
thank you ron we're also honored
today to have the undersheriff with us
the foundation is an independent entity
but works very closely
with the sheriff and then the sheriff to
determine
what are the priorities of funding needs
for the police department
and the community safety initiatives
that the department organizes each and
every year
so it's an honor to have you here under
sheriff and i'll turn the podium over to
you
i just want to make a couple of comments
um you know we talk about the foundation
and you've heard of it obviously and all
that but i think a lot of people don't
realize that it's the people that count
right and it's a it's somebody like ron
corey or don
that started this and it's grown into
the future and what you're seeing behind
me
is the future right you hear on the news
about all the talk about police reform
and how we can do better as we move
forward into the future
it's projects like this that the
foundation undertakes educating our kids
the most important thing we can do is
develop them to be better leaders
and to to help run a business like this
that's going up behind me as we move
forward to be the
leader in america and probably the world
and how we train police officers from
around the country so
while you're here today in this tent on
a nice beautiful sunny day
look back beyond this and realize that
this foundation
supports that type of thing and that
this person where'd he go there he is
this person here really supports the
opportunity for your children to become
leaders
and i hope that they decide to come back
and join our department because we need
them
so thank you for being here
congratulations to all the students
and best of luck in your endeavors in
your college career
and thanks to ron and to don and to tom
and the foundation so
everybody enjoy the day thank you very
much
so as ron pointed out the foundation has
come
quite a long ways in the last five or
six years
raising 100 000 a year was pretty much
what the foundation did for
many years the foundation uh turned 20
years old last year
so that was probably the most that had
been raised in any one year
the last two years we've raised nearly 8
million dollars in each of those years
and that's because of the generosity of
so many community members and
local businesses supporting us and the
only reason they're supporting
us is because each of you who are on the
force
working for the department and working
for the safety of all of us
much of the money that's been raised
over the
last two years is to support the
training facility that
is going up behind us we are in the
first phase of that training project
our goal for the first phase is 25
million and we have fortunately
have received over 18 million in
commitments for that project
and so because of that funding this
project is on track
to be on time and the first building
delivered by the end of the year
and we look forward to celebrating that
on october 1st
later this year because the response
that's required to incidents like what
happened
at the country music festival is exactly
one of the primary reasons for this
training facility
that will not only be used by metro but
other first responder agencies
here in southern nevada and ultimately
throughout the state
so we felt it was only fitting this year
to
allow all of you to have sort of a first
glimpse at what is being done here
and have the opportunity to receive your
scholarships in such an amazing place
in front of a remarkable facility that
is being built
we had this year 60 applicants for this
scholarship
and which is i'm really an incredible
statistic each and every year that
about 60 young people apply for this
and as ron said he uh sits on the
selection committee as i do
and there's probably not a more
challenging task that we face each year
in figuring out of the 60 who should be
the 10 or 12 that we're offering
scholarships to
each year because everyone who applies
is a remarkable young man or woman
who has demonstrated in the essay that
they've submitted
why it has been a rewarding
and meaningful experience to grow up in
a law enforcement household
and part of this effort is to recognize
and
honor your parents who have served
and continue to serve so honorably for
our community
so it is our pleasure to
present each of you with a certificate
today
recognizing your accomplishment as a
2021
alan beck and new dorsaldo memorial
scholarship winner
so congratulations to each and every one
of you
i'm gonna ask ron and the undersheriff
to come up
so that they can congratulate you
and you'll get your photo taken with
them
our first recipient bevalequa
iii congratulations
our next recipient viviana sarah
congratulations
our next recipient nyaccio
this will be a familiar reunion alexa
darcy
[Music]
right
xavier grabowski
we're trending mask off
[Applause]
jalen mccarthy
oh
charles minute
congratulations
congratulations
next is deshone miles jr
well done congratulations
there you go self
or frisco foreign
jonathan perez
the fearlessness of you congratulations
daniel walton
[Applause]
uh the 12th winner unfortunately uh had
a
baseball game uh conflict today so troy
connell
uh is the 12th recipient so why don't we
give him a round of applause and
extension
well once again congratulations to each
and every one of you
we look forward to providing the check
for your scholarship later this summer
and wishing you all the best
in your academic year ahead
as i said earlier we thought this
setting was appropriate given the scope
of the project behind us and the
importance of that project not only to
the police department but
to our community just as a
update on construction as you can see
the first building has already started
to have the walls put up
and the slab of the second building
which will be behind it
will be poured next week
the roof of this first building is
already
beginning to be constructed and
as i mentioned earlier that first
building will be completed in november
the second building will take a little
bit longer
the second building is going to house an
indoor tactical training village
and that facility uh right now
it looks and will look like when it's
finished a big warehouse
but inside where the training will take
place
will be the recreation of spaces that
our officers and other first responders
might get called to an incident so there
could be a casino floor
an apartment a house a convenience store
a bank a school
there will actually be a roadway running
through the building that will fit
the largest vehicle that lvmpd has as
well as
the largest fire truck in southern
nevada
so that there can be some vehicular
access training
in addition to the interior training in
the buildings
so as i mentioned i will be celebrating
that first building on october 1st
and until then i hope you all have and
continue to be safe
and uh thank you again for the amazing
young men and women that each of you are
and who you represent and to your
parents thank you for
all your service uh and everything you
do to keep
southern nevada an incredibly safe and
healthy place
there are refreshments here for you to
enjoy
i feel free to take family photos in
front of the
stop and repeat and enjoy the rest
of the congratulations again thank you
for being here